this polish family owned business
produces clogs for the German and
Scandinavian markets its factory is
located in north eastern Poland boss on
jay seville ski planned to build a plant
in the neighboring russian region of
Kaliningrad wages are lower there and
what is cheaper but Russian officials
have told him that polish companies
aren't welcome Russian authorities were
against me investing their the locals
were nice to me but the officials didn't
want to play ball and his company isn't
being welcomed with open arms even
though authorities have made it much
easier for residents living near the
border to cross locals from Poland and
Russia can obtain this special long-term
visa but while investment isn't
benefiting from the special visas own
trade has been booming as the ruble
depreciate seeeeee more and more
Russians have been traveling to Poland
for shopping sprees above all they're
buying goods no longer available in
Russia due to sanctions you know sort of
really everyone wants to come here
because there's more to choose from and
it's cheaper I bought some shoes today
Brazil on you and the growing political
tension between the EU and Russia is
being felt in north eastern Poland two
popular tourist destinations and the
shores of the Baltic are deserted this
restaurant has seen turnover dive by
more than fifty percent as Russian
visitors lose interest in sight seeing
and eating out
zovem will not fall within the trend is
towards fewer and fewer Russian visitors
I think I can count the last Russian
patrons here on one hand us the goshti
ROC and this Porsche dealership near
Gdansk once flourished thanks to wealthy
Russian customers from Kaliningrad
before the crisis it sold at least five
everyday now it's closer to five per
week but the franchise is putting on a
brave face on the downturn so we are
trying to stay away from the politics
and just to focus on our job back to the
shoe factory businessman i'm jay seville
ski says he still wants to establish a
factory in Kaliningrad despite the
obstacles but with no end to the
political sanctions in sight he's having
to bide his time